You have no idea.
You have no idea what you just have
unleashed across this entire country in
this world. You have no idea. You have
no idea the fire that you have ignited
within this wife.
The cries of this widow will echo around
the world like a battlecry.
>> It is genuinely sad what she's going
through. But you guys, you really need
to. You have to be consistent. There are
hundreds of thousands of widows in Gaza
and kids that's been massacred. If you
don't have double standards, you will
not just cry for one man, but also what
happens in Gaza.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran. Gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well.
Inshallah, some of you guys might notice
my daughter is right there. So, don't
worry, it's my daughter there. Don't
worry, it's not some kind of a ghost or
whatever. Um, doing this video
inshallah. As you can see, this is Erica
Kirk, the wife of Charlie Kirk, who is
mourning. She is a widow. And this is a
video footage we're going to react to of
her speech. Um, we're going to anal
analyze some stuff, take some reminders
out of it, some benefits out of it,
because it's something that we all can
benefit from. Um, but this is the
footage of um her at his funeral and at
the casket. Um, let's just watch for
oursel. It is sad. It is sad and it is
heartbreaking. Let's watch it.
I love you.
I love you. I love you. I know.
>> I love you.
I love you.
God bless you.
So, as you can see, and there's, you
know, I've seen some videos of people.
Sadly, it's conspiracy. you know, she's
wearing a ring that says G is the
Illuminati and it gets a really petty,
guys. I mean to say it gets a bit
ridiculous and petty, you know, oh, look
at that and this, you know, there's so
many speculations made here, you know,
and it's not a conspiracy that the whole
world except Zionist believe that Israel
carried out this assassination. The
hallmarks of Israel is written all over
it and Charlie Kirks, if you see my past
videos I've done, him turning against
them was the last straw. So, we want to
see the speech. I'd really I haven't I
want to watch it as well and see what
Erica Kirk had to say. Um, and
obviously, like I said before, brother
sisters, I strongly strongly strongly
like viciously um disagreed with uh what
Charlie Kirk said. Yes. And let me be
honest, I believe that legacy that he
left being pro- genocidal and but
towards the end waking up again, it
shows that he was brainwashed. Even
though we hate what he said, but he was
clearly brainwashed because it shows
towards the end towards the end of his
life, he was changing his opinion. And
once again,
his wife and his children are innocent
in this matter. And that is what's so
heartbreaking because I have my daughter
here, you know, and imagine and towards
the end, she talks about coming home and
the young three-year-old daughter. My
daughter's four. Yes. And I have a
2-year-old and I have an 8-year-old.
Imagine being asked where is my where is
dad? So let's watch it and analyze it
for ourel inshallah. Um there is a few
things I find odd but nothing that deep
but I just want to carry. Let's watch
the speech that she gave.
>> My wife Usha for their love and support.
You guys honored my husband so well
bringing him home.
You both are tremendous.
I want to thank President Trump and his
incredible family for the same.
Mr. President,
my husband loved you.
And he knew that you loved him, too. He
did. Your friendship was amazing.
You supported him so well, as did he for
you.
Two days ago, my husband Charlie went to
see the face of his savior and his god.
>> Just to dissect this, uh, you know, yes,
their relationship was very quite
strong, but that was not the same when
Charlie Kirk went to tell him not to get
involved in attack in Iran. and he was
scolded by Trump and knowing that I
found it so bizarre and not and I'm not
trying to ruin this whole you know she's
obviously it's a speech etc she believes
this maybe she doesn't know and and and
the husband would come and open up to
their wives they would if they have a
good wife they open up to their wives
and you saw Donald Trump when he was
asked about Charlie Kirk I mean I was
absolutely gobsmacked where he was just
like just brushed it off and just said
oh yeah look what we're doing over there
and I found that so bizarre
>> I think very good and by the way right
There you see all the trucks. They've
just started construction of the new BO
for the White House, which is something
they've been trying to get, as you know,
for about 150 years. And so odd. And
maybe Erica Kirk believes or is in
assumption that their relationship was
good. Maybe Charlie Kirk was holding
this away from her. And as men, we're
like that. Sometimes we do not when we
know that our life is in danger, etc. We
do not like to make our families panic.
You know, I don't I've had situations
where there's been death threats, etc. I
would never go and tell my my wife, my
mom, etc. And I know even Muhammad,
there's been situations where, you know,
we've, you know, there's been things I
don't need to go into detail. But we
don't tell our family members because we
don't want them to be worried or upset.
So, I think this is something that he
kept away from Erica Kirk, uh, his wife,
and she's not, she doesn't know. And I
do highly urge her, I don't know if she
should watch this video or not, for her
to really look into the cause, the
actual cause that Charlie Kirk was, you
know, implementing when he was slowly
changing his opinions and criticizing
Israel. So let's carry on, inshallah.
>> Charlie always said that when he was
gone, he he wanted to be remembered for
his courage and for his faith.
And in the Quran, Allah takes us tells
us to be to be standards of justice even
if it's against ourel or kin with us. We
as Muslims we are consistent morally not
strategically. That's the reason why we
don't like oh strategically that
benefits Muslims. So we turn no no we
are consistent. So there was a lot of
stuff Charlie K said we agree with when
it comes to conservative values as
Muslims. I'll be honest with you I would
rather live under a Christian rule than
a liberal rule all day every day. And we
we we supported that. We supported his
you know talking about the
transgenderism and the LGBTQ etc. and
this uh stuff about our kids being
brainwashed. 100% the Muslims are
behind. Muslims are the ones at the
forefront fighting. So there were so
many things that aligned with us with
the far right and the Muslims 100%. But
sadly he was also known for something
that we are consistent morally which is
killing of innocent people. That's a no
no for us as Muslims. That's a no no for
us especially innocent men, women and
children.
Erica Kirk, you're crying. You're a
widow. Your children are crying. They've
lost their father. There are hundreds of
thousands of widows in Gaza.
We have to be real. And we have to be
just. If there's anyone that is moved, I
was moved by this speech. I'll be honest
with you. When I saw it, I was saddened.
I was genuinely saddened for his wife
and his children. And also, we do not
condone for him to be killed and
assassinated in this way. But what about
the hundreds of thousands of people in
Gaza that sa sadly Charlie Kirk was
brainwashed to promote as it's not
genocide or that even though he changed
his mind later on which somehow redeems
himself maybe
>> according to his purpose
already I have seen the worldwide
outpouring of love for my husband I've
heard the testimonies from people my
husband inspired to get married to start
families to seek out a relationship with
God it's the most important most
important one of all
>> again what she's saying here is so to us
is And it's amazing to hear because we
want people to go back to their nuclear
family, their traditional values, be
they're Christians or whatever for that
matter because that is what keeps our
societ society intact. That's how
Muslims and Christians and Jews have
lived with the same values. Not this
values of Tommy Robinson going sleeping
around with prostitutes, snorting
cocaine, beating his wife like a Yemen
who threw a chopper board to his wife,
Paul Golding who was locking up Jada.
These are not the values. These aren't
the values. the values that the British
people that actually lived in talking
about patriotism. You bloody morons.
Yes. Tony Robinson freedom of speech
event. You you have no Christian values,
man. You're not a Christian. What are
you talking about? Yes. Oh, fake child.
What are we talking about? In the 1970s,
1970s, look at the 1900s. Look how the
British men and women were dressed. They
look like Muslims. They look like
Muslims. And even in the 70s, there were
women who were shown a woman with a
cleavage. Yeah. And they were they were
like, "Oh, that's that's a there, you
know, We will never dress up like that.
They have Islamic values. That's what
you're talking about.
>> The evildoers
responsible for my husband's
assassination have no idea what they
have done. They killed Charlie because
he preached a message of patriotism,
faith, and of God's merciful love. But
they should all know this. If you
thought that my husband's mission was
powerful before, you have no idea.
You have no idea what you just have
unleashed across this entire country in
this world. You have no idea. You have
no idea the fire that you have ignited
within this wife.
The cries of this widow will echo around
the world like a battlecry.
>> And again, like I said before, guys, I
get like I get I get a bit of goosebumps
because it is genuinely sad. It is
genuinely sad what she's going through.
But you guys, you really need to if you
have to be consistent. There are
hundreds of thousands of widows in Gaza
and kids that's been massacred. If you
do not have double standards, you will
not just cry for one man but also what's
happens in Gaza or across the world,
whoever they are, Christian, Muslim,
Jew, Hindu, Sikh, whatever, you will be
consistent. If you're not, you are a
hypocrite. You are a hypocrite. those
who you are watching this from the far
right and a message to Charlie Charlie
Kirk's wife Erica Kirk you want to
promote and make his cause stronger good
connecting people back to God
traditional values Muslims are behind
this cause but also you need to
understand your husband left with the
reality of Israel and Benjamin Netanyahu
and those who bullied him and those who
bullied him behind the scenes remember
that Erica Kirk you have to remember
that if you want to put his genuine
cause which was towards the end of his
life, he realized how dangerous Israel
was and if anyone dared to turn back,
they will be assassinated. So bear that
in mind and his cause should be that
cause.
>> To everyone listening tonight across
America, the movement my husband build
will not die. It won't. I refuse to let
that happen. It will not die. All of us
will refuse to let that happen. No one
will ever forget my husband's name and I
will make sure of it.
it will confess the Lord Jesus Christ
who rose from the dead then they will be
saved
>> and for those who are watching this who
may be non-Muslims who are watching this
just so don't know as Muslims we believe
in Christ believe in Jesus as a prophet
as a messiah that he will come back in
his miraculous birth in his mother we
honor them we honor them yes in Judaism
they are told this is why this Christian
Judeo-Christian values is a nonsense
oxymoron because they believe that Jesus
burning his own fees in hellfire. They
call his mother an adulterer.
If there's anything you are more closer
to us than Judaism with due respect.
With all due respect. So if you want to
be consistent, yes, we believe in that.
But we do not believe Jesus is God. He
never claimed to be God. We believe in
his message. We believe he was the way,
the truth, and the life. And nobody went
to God Almighty except through him. We
believe at his time that was him. Yes.
But we do not believe he's God. And he
never deemed himself to be God. So we
invite you to Islam to worship the one
true God. Like Jesus said, the one true
God is the father.
>> Most important of all, if you aren't a
member of a church, I beg you to join
one, a bibleelving church. Our battle is
not simply a political one. Above all,
it is spiritual. That is spiritual. The
spiritual warfare is palpable.
Charlie loved his savior with all of his
heart. And he wanted every one of you to
know him, too. He wanted everyone to
know that if they confess, if they
confess the Lord Jesus Christ, who rose
from the dead, then they will be saved.
Hear me when I say this. Nobody is ever
too young to know the gospel. Nobody.
Nobody is ever too young to get involved
with saving this beautiful country, this
country my husband loved and still
loves. And nobody is ever too old
either.
>> I mean, there you go. I can I disagree
with that? No. If you are calling
yourself Christians, you don't read the
Bible. You don't attend the churches.
You don't follow in the commandments.
I'm so sorry. With all your respect, I
respect the fact is saying go back to
your Bible. And as Muslims, should we
tell you something? Go back to your
Bible. We like I said before, we as
Muslims, we'd rather live on the
Christian rule. Except if they're not
the crusaders, they're going to massacre
us. Men, women, and children. No, thank
you very much. But at least their values
align with us
when I got home last night.
Gigi, our daughter just ran into our my
arms
and I talked to her and she said,
"Mommy, I missed you. I said I missed
you, baby." She goes, "Where's daddy?
What do you tell a three-year-old? She's
three."
And this is why guys when I hear this
like I said before you might disagree
with Charles Cook and I did and I hated
his actions for the sake of God for sake
of God I hated that he someone who
believes in Jesus that they deem to be
so love somebody who believes it who
believes in Jesus and they claim this
Jesus loves his enemies and this that
subhan Allah to hear him defend the
genocide was shocking it didn't make
sense it was hypocr Y
and because of that this is why I say we
do not condone his death neither do we
mourn it but for those who are crossing
limits even the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him when a Jewish man died he
got up out of respect out of respect so
guys you need to understand don't
Charlie Kirk the old Charlie Kirk before
you change yes or you want to call him
the president whatever he's not our
teacher he's not my teacher that's why I
am sad saddened because of his children
or what's going on. I'm saddened. And
for those who want to be consistent, you
have to give the freedom of speech that
you believe in, which we don't believe
in. You believe in freedom of speech.
Then those who come and laugh and don't
don't don't say nothing to them. Be
consistent in your worldview. In our
worldview, that's wrong. They shouldn't.
In your worldview, that's okay. Be
consistent. Be consistent. That's why I
do not condone what's happened to him
because he is not my teacher. The
prophet Muhammad, the best man to walk
this earth, did not teach us. Yes.
>> I said, "Baby, daddy loves you so much.
Don't you worry. He's on a He's on a
work trip with Jesus, so he can afford
your blueberry budget.
And my goodness, am I so humbled to
witness Charlie, you alongside Jesus
right now, doing what you always want to
do, baby. Making heaven crowded, right?
That's what it's all about."
>> And brothers and sisters, what else can
you say? What else can you say? But let
this be a a a reminder to every single
one of us. Allah says in the Quran,
You are busy with the worldly affairs,
the riches, the fame until you visit the
graves. And know surely you're going to
know. And know surely you are going to
know. Brothers and sisters, invest in
what really matters is the hereafter.
The one true God is Allah, God Almighty,
God that created Jesus, Moses, and send
them as messengers. And I invite the
Christians who are watching this to
Islam. The one true God is Allah and he
sent Jesus and Jesus praised God.
And like I said before, it's very, very
sad. Very sad having my daughter here in
the back.
It's sad. It's sad. That's why we say
guys, him or many like him are not our
teachers and Charlie Kirk did change his
views. And Erica Kirk, if you want to
make his mission carry on, speak out
against Israel and its crimes because
that's what Charlie Kirk did before they
assassinated him. Goodbye.